so we talk a lot about climate but how's
the actual environment doing the soil
and the air and the water well whales
and dolphins are washing them dead in
the Northeast apparently because of wind
farm construction and now there is
unfolding what may be the biggest
environmental disaster of all it's
called red tide it's covering 100 square
miles tonight in the Gulf of Mexico so
red tide occurs when colonies of algae
grow out of control toxins in red tide
kill fish in huge numbers
red tide also makes it hard for people
to breathe but it's also true that red
tide may cause ALS Lou Gehrig's so this
is a huge problem that is widely ignored
for some reason Paul Allen Cox is an
ethnobotanist he's the documentarian who
did toxic puzzle and we're happy to have
him join us tonight thank you so much
for coming on so you did this amazing
documentary terrifying documentary on
red tide and yet I think most people
aren't aware of what a threat it is tell
us if you would
what red tide does to people potentially
yeah thank you Mr Carlson there's been
red Tides along the west coast of
Florida for oh gosh a century and a half
They're Not Unusual and they produce
various neurotoxins that people detect
by getting stinging in the eyes and
sometimes respiratory distress sometimes
they poison shellfish we've looked at
other types of harmful algal blooms
called cyanobacteria and found they have
a toxin that not only causes a cancer
but also can cause ALS and that's
something that we're monitoring very
closely with the outflows from Lake
Okeechobee in Florida
I mean I don't think I think there's a
consensus that ALS has got to be the
scariest or certainly one of the
scariest diseases that people get so
anything that might cause it it seemed
would set off like alarm bells and
people would be completely freaked out
about it I don't get the sense that the
response to this is very urgent
well fortunately ALS is a very rare
disease but we found that a toxin called
bmaa increases your risk of getting ALS
our colleagues Dr Elijah stommel at
Dartmouth University Neurology
department our colleagues in Florida
have found that if you're near these
cyanobacterial blooms that your risk
goes up so this is completely avoidable
people should just stay away from these
cyanobacterial Tides if they have asthma
or serious neurological conditions just
stay indoors and stay away till it's
clear and I think there's a real strong
consensus of scientists that this is a
problem we can actually solve just by
cleaning up the water a little bit I
think it'll really go a long ways
cleaning up the water it's just nice to
hear somebody to say that out loud
because you rarely do at this point for
some reason we appreciate your coming on
Dr Paul Allen Cox thank you
thank you very much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight